et
nous accueillons axel mais bonjour axel
bonjour on a débuté par cette une du
figaro oui emmanuel macron qui tente une
médiation avec vladimir poutine rompant
le tête-à-tête russo américain dans la
crise ukrainienne le président français
veut faire entendre aujourd'hui la voix
de l'europe auprès du chef du kremlin et
cela pourrait bien être un virage dans
la politique russe d'emmanuel macron
poursuit le figaro car après avoir
longtemps espéré le réchauffement des
relations avec moscou les mots
l'attitude du président se sont durcies
la russie est devenue une puissance de
déséquilibre affirme désormais le
président français et l'opinion vous
allez le voir renchérit la stratégie sur
le fil de macron ne pas laisser le
monopole américain discuter avec moscou
les rassurer à ce que ce dialogue
inquiète en envoyant des troupes vers
l'est la voix française est étroite mais
pas sans issue avec pour illustrer ce
titre à la stratégie sur le fil de
maquereaux on poutine face au président
français et puis un représentant de
l'otan et avec les missiles qui sont
pointés vers eux il dit il faut que vous
arrêtiez de dramatiser voyez c'est sûr
que c'est un petit peu compliqué
d'éviter dans ces cas là les échos
s'intéressent pour leur part aux
conséquences économiques d'une
dégradation de la situation géopolitique
en arrêt cet article la bce la banque
centrale européenne a demandé aux
grandes banques des informations sur
l'aex exposition en russie l'italian
l'italien unicredit à l'autrichien
raiffeisen et le groupe français société
générale font partie des établissements
étrangers les plus implantées en russie
la société générale via sa filiale dont
vous devez mener ici le le mot à l'écran
rosbank se positionne même à la société
générale comme le premier groupe
bancaire international auprès des
particuliers russe à propos d' économie
la presse espagnole salue le retour de
l'emploi c'est par exemple la une d'el
país l'espagne a créé huit mille huit
cent quarante mille huit cent quarante
mille emplois l'an dernier le taux le
plus élevé depuis 2005 avant même la
pandémie donc et avant même la crise
financière de 2008 le chômage tombe à
13,1 3% là c'est le plus bas niveau
depuis 14 ans même si souligne el país
un emploi sur quatre est temporaire et
le gouvernement tentent d'ailleurs avec
difficulté un adopter une réforme pour
limiter le recours à l'intérim en
espagne sur le front du coc vis de
l'inde comme de nombreux autres pays
relâche ces restrictions et c'est la une
du times of india fin du couvre-feu le
week-end à new delhi les restaurants et
les écoles demeurent
les restaurants les cinémas peuvent
rouvrir avec une jauge de 50% donc 50%
de la capacité en revanche les écoles
demeurent pour l'instant fermé ce qui
nous amène vous allez là aussi le voir
cet article du new york times les
espoirs s'estompe pour une génération
perdue des centaines de millions
d'élèves sont touchés les écoles sont
fermées par un terminant intermittence à
depuis le début de la pandémie et elles
sont souvent les écoles les premiers
endroits à fermer et les derniers à
rouvrir et puis un enfant qui grelottent
de froid ce dessin est publié dans al
qods al arabia al arabi et il dit tout
sur la situation des camps de réfugiés
dans le nord de la syrie sous la neige
ce dessin qui semble dire que fait le
monde arable face à cette situation nous
sommes à une semaine de la cérémonie
d'ouverture des jeux d'hiver les
villages olympiques sont eux déjà ouvert
oui les trois villages car il y a trois
sites et ils sont prêts se félicite le
global times qui colportent la bonne
parole du pouvoir chinois le journal
anglophone s'enorgueillit que la chine
dispose de la plus grande équipe
olympique de son histoire pour les jeux
d'hiver 176 athlètes dont 20 issues des
minorités ethniques notamment tibétains
et ouïghours évidemment avis différent
dans ce dessein qui tient lieu des 10
tôt pour le washington post la devise
olympique
plus vite plus haut et ensuite c'est
génocide donc la devise olympique qui
est transformé le site du japon m dos
dames nous apprend là c'est plus
croustillants ou en tout cas à plus
sympathiques nous apprend que les
athlètes sur les podiums recevront des
fleurs des roses en tricot réalisé par
des amis par des mamies par des
grands-mères de shanghai une version en
laine a été choisi parce que
contrairement à un vrai bouquet
périssables le bouquet en laine peut
servir de souvenirs avis et oui c'est
mignon allez on va terminer avec le
championnat d'orgue handball masculin la
france joue ce soir contre la suède une
place en finale oui ça se passe à
budapest les bleus sont champions
olympiques les suédois sont vice
champions du monde et nikola karabatic
est toujours là la star français
s'apprête à fêter ses 20 ans en bleu il
a remporté lui trois fois déjà le
championnat d'europe 20 ans en bleu à 37
ans
comme l'écrit l'équipe c'est une bête de
compétition on va écouter on leur
souhaite bonne chance on va continuer à
parler de sport et merci accepte